i've had a lot of guys
on this show who lived through the coke
the miami 80s like
the cocaine wars where it was just
people dying left and right
you know more i think what was the one
of the crazy things about your
documentary that really
hit me was the amount of deaths that
were in miami there was a crazy
statistic about the people that died in
miami during like a certain like that
decade
yeah well not only did did you know
homicides peak in about 80 to 83 in the
city of miami
but you had an overflow of bodies
um and you had uh burger king who's
headquartered in miami
uh donated refrigerated trucks
to the morgue so that they could store
literally stack
dead bodies up and in that era
there was a year in the early 1980s
where
upwards of 25
of the bodies in at the dade county
medical examiner's office
had wounds from automatic gunfire so
they were essentially killed by machine
gun fire
25 of the corpses i mean
you had craig 1980 was a crazy year
because you had this like perfect storm
of um the drug wars
the marielle boat lift which people
who've seen scarface know what the mario
boat lift
uh was uh and then you had um
these riots that broke out after an
all-white jury acquitted white
police officers from miami but they the
the case was in tampa because they got a
change of
of a venue because of the of how high uh
uh the emotions were down here they had
beaten
a black motorcyclist an insurance
salesman to death
at the side of the road and then tried
to cover it up
and they were tried and and acquitted in
tampa
um and uh miami
you burned um 18 people were killed
there was
she's like a billion dollars in damage
there are some blocks this is 1980
and there are some neighborhoods and
some blocks in those neighborhoods that
have never been redeveloped
since they were burned down um in those
demonstrations in 1980
uh arthur mcduffie was his name they
were known as the mcduffie riots
um or the mcduffie demonstrations and um
they um so miami
in 1980 was insane and you had a lot of
the
uh some of the people came over during
the mariel boatlift castro famously
emptied his prisons and his hospitals
and his mental institutions in cuba
and shipped everyone over to miami it
nearly bankrupted
the four southern counties of florida
monroe dave broward and palm beach
because there was just no resources
to can you imagine getting a hundred and
fifty thousand people
many of whom needed food shelter
medicine the kids need school health
care i mean like
it was an insane uh uh and it just all
happened in less than six months
suddenly 150
000 new people uh all you know as a
burden on
on public resources and so um you know
long story even longer um i heard i
remember i said everybody
in this town who was alive in that era
has a story
you know oh yeah some of them have
several stories but any line of work you
were in
certainly a lawyer um a cop a journalist
they have grace but everybody
so i knew a guy a doctor who worked as a
trauma surgeon
at jackson memorial which is our like er
our big city like trauma center
it's where all you know uh where all
major trauma
uh uh cases go in the city um
one night he's working in the er and he
gets a
a mariolito who was a marielle refugee
uh who was in miami beach
and got into you know some kind of
[ __ ] shootout over whatever
and uh he he was shot in a certain
spot on his body i can't remember where
but the doctor who's bilingual you know
said to him in spanish he said listen
you're very lucky
if that wound if that uh a bullet
had hit you just like a few millimeters
or centimeters over here
you would have basically you would bled
out like right at the scene you never
would have made it to the hospital
several days later another marielle
refugee
comes into the er while he's working
with a gunshot wound
in exactly the same spot where he told
the other guy
that if you get shot there you'll die
and the guy bled
out and died he can't prove it he
doesn't know it
but he was almost positive that that was
a retaliatory
uh you know shooting and murder uh in
for the for the
the previous patient uh that that he had
seen
um i smile it's not funny but it's it's
[ __ ] up but it's like
this kind of [ __ ] happened all the time
in that era
so you get a guy like george or jorge
who just
who lived an extraordinary life and all
i will say is
um certainly a life worth making a
documentary
uh about so george valdez who came on my
podcast
i saw this story i saw that he did like
one podcast before i had him on here
and he lives in orlando and i was a
little bit skeptical of him i'm not
going to lie when he when i before i met
him in person
and then he pulled up to my podcast and
a [ __ ] rolls-royce ghost he pulled up
to my
studio driving a ghost with his son
i was like what the [ __ ] are like
so you stashed all your money obviously
like you had money left over
when you went to prison like or did he
like i had i was like how did you make
all this back
no i i'm pretty sure like listen i i
don't know that he had no money but
you know he was living large and so you
know it's like we talked about you know
broke kids experiencing a sudden wealth
event
this kid was barely in his 20s and he's
making you know he's he's making
tens of millions of dollars a month for
crying out loud so
believe me he found i'm sure exciting
ways to squander it um
and also you know a lot of these guys
literally buried it or gave it to
friends it was just too much cash like
literally to physically there was no
place to put
the money after a while so a lot of it i
think he lost but he came out
you know he got a master's he's very
proud of you know
his education and he became an
entrepreneur and he and he started some
businesses and he sold some businesses
legitimate
legitimate businesses and i think he
built himself you know i think he felt
like
i was a kid in miami during the cocaine
boom
i fell it he was already like working in
his account
as an accountant i think he was working
at the federal reserve bank like
right a different path in life
you know and he knows that now and he
made a choice
at the time to go for that easy money
and
a lot of it he made but then he paid
quite a dear price for he went to prison
three times
if you include panama which was a
horrific and torturous literally
torturous
uh and traumatizing experience for him
and then went to federal prison twice in
the states
um because he got out and and [ __ ] up
again you know went right back into the
into the business uh and then he made a
decision he found god and he said like
i clearly chose the wrong path because i
can be rich and successful and fulfilled
if i do something legitimate i can be
you know
in a lot of ways people were sort of
guilty by geography you have to realize
that if you were a young
kid especially a young immigrant kid
coming to america with
you know the the mythology that you you
grew up with with
the american dream right and you come to
america
and a bunch of your friends and people
you know and kids in the neighborhood
are in this business and they are
rolling
that must be what you think the american
dream is you know what i mean like
you're talking about athletes young and
making money like
what do they know what do these kids
know they know the american dream
and they see everybody around them
driving rolls royces and driving
porsches and driving mercedes and they
go
oh this is the american dream you come
to america
you smuggle or you sell coke or whatever
and and you
you're a millionaire that's what happens
you know you know so i think that they
had a warped
view of it but again young kids when
you're in miami it was miami
we don't have any indigenous industry
you know um
most of florida doesn't we're a factory
town we sell the sun
we sell the florida dream we sell
tourism and development and real estate
growth
growth is our hustle in the state of
florida
you know and so that's what you know you
see these guys do
all these other kids and there was
literally pockets
you know and and and subsets and
subcultures within communities
where everybody you knew was in some way
involved in the business and so a lot of
kids fell into that
that's not to make excuses but just to
sort of understand the perspective in
the moment
and listen you know he was scared
straight george got it
got a couple wake-up calls and and
literally found god
and converted and decided that um
there was a way that i can be just as
successful and happy
and fulfilled doing it legitimately and
that's what i think he uh
that's what i think bought him that the
car you saw not some of his earlier
cars or or planes but certainly i hope
the car that you saw
was was legit was legitimate
no you're totally right the geography
thing the right place in the right time
if you were in
south florida anywhere in south florida
during that time there's a
damn good chance that you were involved
in that world somehow
like i had like manny pwig you're
familiar with who manny puyg is the wild
boy
wild guy who does all the um [ __ ]
wrestles alligators and sharks he
i had no idea but he went to prison for
some for
being involved in that world like
smuggling some [ __ ] through florida like
a minor thing
but he was in prison in north florida
for a couple of years
um and i had no [ __ ] clue but he
happened to be living in south florida
during that time
listen mickey monday the you know the
the smuggler on uh
who we interviewed for cooking cowboys
the first one um you know
back in the in an era when if you were
making 13 grand
15 grand a year that was like that was
an income
um you're talking about late 70s early
80s right so um
he'd have friends who come out
say once a month
these are the lowest dudes on the totem
pole
they're doing grunt work manual labor
they're helping unload
packages you know bundles of coke off a
plane
throwing it into a car or a truck
whatever manual labor
for one night a month let's say
um maybe twice a month if they were
super busy but let's for the sake of the
math let's do
let's do one night a month he would pay
those guys
5 dollars cash
for that one night of work okay so
that means that some guy making 13 grand
a year 15 grand a year
on on the books as a tax paying citizen
has an extra 60 000
cash tax-free off the books
kicking around that year and that's only
if he works
one night a month and he's not even in
the drug business this guy just came out
to do
manual labor for one night i mean that's
that's why i said the trickle down
economics that like that's how that
that happened so the lowest guy in the
totem pole
is making like four times
his legit salary a year
in cash tax-free just doing this so like
you can imagine how much you know
the guys actually moving the product
we're making so my question is this
someone comes to you and says hey
i'll give you five grand you're a buddy
of yours come out just help us unload
and some of the guys did it just for fun
just to tell their you know their kids
someday like i was a pirate you know
what i mean like
just for the story but some guys did it
on the regular and they made a
[ __ ] ton of money and they did not
do that right now for that amount of
money they did not buy drugs they did
not sell drugs they did not smuggle
drugs they just did some math they
they moved a pr you know they moved a
bundle of this to the and um
that's not to say they would have gotten
busted but you know you get my point
in their head just to rationalize [ __ ]
it i'm gonna go out
for one night a month right like you
said in 2021
you would you know you would leap at
that opportunity and you would you would
rationalize it you'd say
i'm not in the drug business i'm not
selling drugs i'm not buying drugs
i'm not smuggling drugs i'll just go out
and do some manual labor for
you know for one day oh yeah
for an extra sixty thousand dollars yeah
again i'm not making excuses
but i think it's hard you know when
you're when you're judging somebody
and their and their lifestyle and the
and the the decisions they've made in
their lives
it's hard when you're not in in the
moment you know i'm trying to
be as vivid as i can about it to say
like nobody was living your life for my
life or anybody
they were living their own life at a
really
surreal and dynamic and transitional
time
and unique time in an american city